haven't taught many valuable life
lessons and I appreciate I appreciate
every day Mama June's daughter Anna
chickadee Cardwell celebrates her
daughter's graduation how has fifth
grade prepared me for Middle School
since I am going to the sixth grade I am
going to give some thanks to his party
Anna posted this sweet video of 10 year
old Caitlyn thanking her teachers it's
fun adventure watching Caitlyn grow up
along with seven-year-old Kylie's
musical performance
the caption I am one proud mama right
now give me a minute while I go cry my
eyes out I am so proud of my girls and
everything they have accomplished do you
keep up with your girls on social media
yeah I'll be I I'll be commenting on the
thing when Anna goes live I'll be all up
they know it Mama don't ever stop being
Mama Anna's heartwarming post comes amid
a challenging time for the 28 year old
who's been battling cancer since March
it's a adrenal carcinoma only 200 people
in the world have it it's a rare cancer
it's very aggressive how it all like
happened is in September end of August
she went to the hospital with back pain
she had a cysts on her kidneys she got
it removed that night she had a biopsy
it kind of fascia stage two they claim
they got every bit of it out she'd have
anything to worry about it Flash Forward
two months later they said everything
was still out Flash Forward to January
they said there was a spot that they
seen Flash Forward to February
when they she went to Atlanta doctor
when she got done she got diagnosed with
stage four cancer so it happened very
quickly
um it's in her lungs her liver her
kidneys and her spleen on the left side
and it has
moved very rapidly and grew very rapidly
but in recent weeks glimmers of Hope
Anna posted this image earlier this
month updating fans that the chemo is
working and things are looking good how
are spirits
um depends on what day it is like all of
us like honestly there's days that I
don't know whether to scream or get mad
or get angry or be happy or you know try
to go through the day not only did Anna
attend her daughter's big day but she
was also there for her younger sister
Alana's graduation last week
[Music]